so this is a really interesting story
and i know many of you have been
emailing me saying david you have to
cover this
i don't know how many of you expect me
to cover it in this way though so let's
dig right into it
fox news um i guess uh we'd call him
reporter
uh correspondent peter ducey the son of
steve ducey
also a fox uh host tried to embarrass
georgia democratic senate challenger
john ossoff on air
and it backfired horribly with john
ossoff delivering
a perfectly timed mic drop but
very important what jon ossoff said
happens to be untrue
and we should also care about that so
i'm telling you
the truth here what assaf said was
rhetorically brilliant
but it was not factually accurate so
let's get to it georgia democratic
senate candidate rafael warnock
has had old assault allegations against
him reinvigorated
and they relate to his family life
which he's already discussed fox host
peter ducey
brings these allegations up not to
warnock but to john ossoff
and ossoff executes a perfectly timed
brilliantly calculated and calibrated
rebuttal it is a textbook example of
rhetorical skill
when dealing with hostile media let's
take a look a quick one while we've got
yet any any concern
that the allegations of wrongdoing
against reverend warnock could
possibly be a drag on the democratic
ticket next week
none whatsoever reverend warnock
addressed this issue a year ago
and here's the bottom line kelly lefler
has been campaigning with a klansman
kelly lefler has been campaigning with a
klansman
and so she is stooping to these vicious
personal attacks
to distract from the fact that she's
been campaigning with a former member of
the ku klux klan
i mean we deserve better than that here
in georgia and i want to encourage
everybody to make a plan to vote on
tuesday thank you so much
thank you mr assaf very much all right
rhetorically
that is brilliant the pauses the
repetition
the redirection i mean it is really
perfect
john office is brilliant at this it also
happens not to be accurate and that has
not received the coverage it should
probably get and i'd be doing everybody
in my audience a disservice if i didn't
point this out rhetorical skills
do not necessarily equate to factually
based dialogue
right wing host ben shapiro is a great
example of this he will
quickly rebut any argument you throw at
him and he will
sound confident doing it but the
arguments are often bogus
ossoff said that georgia republican
senate candidate kelly lefler
has been campaigning with a klansman
that is really not true in spirit you
might be able to find some way
where you can say the letter of it
approximates accuracy
it is true kelly leffler was pictured
alongside a former
member of the kkk named chester doles
chester doles was sentenced to prison in
the 90s for assaulting a black man
he was a member of the kkk but to say
that lefleur was campaigning with a
klansman
it's really not correct the leftler
campaign immediately said she has no
idea who this guy is she took a bunch of
pictures with everybody who wanted one
at that event
she condemns everything the kkk stands
for they would have kicked the guy out
if they had known who he was
so it's possible lefleur has a soft spot
for white supremacists
independent of this event but when aseph
says leffler campaigned with a klansman
we're stooping to the sort of character
assassination stuff that they do
because there is no evidence cnn agrees
other fact checkers agree to say
kelly leffler campaigned with a clansman
suggests that the klansman was part of
the campaign
that she welcomed the endorsement of a
klansman the clan's been introduced her
uh that is there's no evidence that
that's what took place here so
we must hold ourselves to the same
standard we we have to do it so
john ossoff is brilliant at this stuff
when he has the facts on his side
and he's brilliant at it when he doesn't
have the facts on his side that's what
makes it
all the more important for us to fact
check this stuff and know what's what i
enjoyed the clip i admit i did
it's not accurate lefler is disgusting
she appears to have profited
uh from kovid via her stock trades
and she's a total robot automaton she
can't put together a sensible critique
of her opponent rafael warnock without
repeating the same four lines over and
over about how he's a radical socialist
whatever
but i can't say i have evidence
that kelly leffler campaigned with a
klansman
in the spirit in which john ossoff is
saying it here
great clip not factually accurate
let me know what you think if you are
anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into a doctor's office
right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video